helping college students succeed during
the pandemic is one of the main goals
over at csn and in order to do that
the college of southern nevada is now
distributing free laptops to all
first-time full-time students and that
starts today
csn says current full-time students who
were enrolled for the first time in the
fall
2020 semester were notified of their
eligibility
with most of the
and i'll take over that we had a little
zoom problem there are students who are
facing a lot of barriers to be
successful one of them the proper tools
and proper technology
most of our classes are requiring that
level of connectivity
so csn is standing up as the first enchi
institution to be offering
this type of investment that we're
making in our students because we know
how much those students and their
families are investing in them
students are able to keep the laptops
for the duration of their term with csn
and when they graduate they get to keep
it to start their careers